[Music]
just like that on a Saturday afternoon
[Laughter]
we got so stormed Wednesday night I left
the bong in the bathroom we have no bong
that's when you know you get stoned when
you lose your [__] bong the
understand me we got problems it was
time to go get another [__] bong
that's it
no biggie what oh [__]
please here I'm here but most
importantly you'll hear a little
pre-fight type thing here we know you
some stars [__] so when the afternoon
Lisa at in flavor
[Music]
this Pike is a [__] mule even with no
weed on it it gives you hits what type
of pipe what have you picked up a pipe
hit it three times and got [__] up
with no weed it's got spirits it's got
coward it's got class mink and Gordie
got personality oh yeah she came from
Planet clip [__]
please don't people that make you go on
this lonely speeds out of it
[Music]
hit that mule we hit that meal with no
shame there's more where that came from
there you go that that oh [__] let me
hit that meal feed again the more we get
uncle Joey
[Music]
senior smoke gets me ice crystals lungs
out well you take a little pen see his
for you got take deep it's mix it's wait
hold on hold on to it the right way here
[Music]
mix it up a little bit nice Philippe so
you get the full effect
[Music]
she came from Planet Clinton she came
from there we go people so you were just
gonna sit there it was gonna be a ho-hum
afternoon then we [__] show up with a
container of [__] gorilla glue you
know I'm saying number four so [__] that
and the horse you rode up on cuz we
ain't [__] around Saturday Sunday's
Thursday Tuesday's whatever they were
here ready a [__] smoke dope and blow
your [__] mind you understand it
oh [__]
that's right [__]
[Music]
it's Saturday you're mowing the lawn or
maybe the Mexicans more on the wood and
you [__] watch them your [__]
jamoke glob that help that [__]
see what it's like to work a day in your
life you're [__] miserable [__] I
just been smoking since I got here it
was my turn my turn started at 6:00 in
the morning time ii come on might turn
you over the gallivant talking about
[__] like the new black is yellow
yeah that's great we'll watch it next
time get the [__] out next time we're
watching Josie the Marines
you don't go to the [__] shoot you
see that I got this [__] feet
training we're going to the Russian
Olympics in Brazil
well anti-doping was gonna come down
big-time doping he's drooling all over
this [__] tank
you don't see me [__] drew I'm
sparking smoking smiling
Betty Ann Brenda [__] it was starting to
scratch [__] a whole new ball a
whole new set of objectives and a whole
new set of goals that was old school
this my friend is new school you got to
blow the old energy up and bring that
new [__] in you know I'm saying with you
looking for we got a bunch of goodies in
that bag though that should be the black
bag right there ilysm we got goodies go
on
[Music]
Gally hoot Gally whoo it's that time of
the day who gives a [__] three clocks
I'm only three stars 600 milligrams just
like that you know why because I don't
want you to think we don't practice what
the [__] would preach in here
it took day in the afternoon where they
drop in 600 milligrams and that's just
an appetizer last a long day
I got a spotted tens I got [__] they're
doing people to see but this is nice
when we get together on Saturday
afternoons no pressure just us like me
in the villa used to do with the kids
and satin let's go to his shed and just
listen to a noun and smoke dope that's
it that's it sounds simple
you [__] have made all the
Gentiles or your [__] gluten
free [__] have made this difficult for
everybody this is all this
put in our mind get a bomb couple bong
hits with your buddies I don't need to
be able to kill the commercial I'll need
people dressed in white around me
jumping up and down and [__] there's
just us rolling over in your mind
[Music]
I'm not no Limburger dad bully don't -
more laughter no you sure for a for
[__] this is as good as it gets
some people want to be millionaires to
be on a yacht and hang out with a bunch
of people don't give a [__] about you
not me it's me and my little Jewish goon
Bali and we'll take over the world just
as tool we're thinking right now reefer
Stars and water that's like [__]
Papillon start [__] you know I'm saying
I'm gonna save somebody stole the Stars
then we have a cuz I see some
[__] creeping around him
that's this mess around round round I'm
at the ice off tonight ten o'clock so 20
minutes spot you know just [__]
around
it's a dirty show so I'm gonna talk
about [__] hit and [__] clinch
with hammers and [__] like that
Kukoc ooh one-way woods coming from
right that's just to let you
[__] know how we do any other
church just in generalities its title
another pipe load please sitting there
going Joey what the [__] am i off and
you over that blowing smoke signals and
I'm Sydney a smoke little guts
[Music]
Oh oh [__] that [__] that [__]
hard sucking I want to see that flame
going into the pipe you just [__]
around
I want the flame has to go a little pipe
there you go there you go now we're back
didn't say they danced this mess around
improve your cardio Rifa in three weeks
with uncle Joey and Lisa I end my turn
that's it I think every turn the reason
you won your red ball your hide was
already let me put this flaming in those
the eyeballs will get written I know
what to tell you
we're in training in this family Moscow
Brazil whatever the [__] they throw at
us we just sit right there
[Music]
yeah coming to it direct you live from
Church studios
it's reefa TV the [__] you guys want to
do watch some stupid show you probably
want let's watch golf live from Myrtle
Beach I don't give a [__] here we go we
were at a party you know what the beauty
about this I'm always at a party in my
[__] head you understand me even when
I was in those dark rooms in a jail cell
I was still having a party in my head
that's where the party starts in the
head oh yeah
[Music]
all we're the boss no lops brings back
to Xenia make it matter all over you
believe this [__] a Jew cookin ZD this
like a [__] Chinese person making
hummus it just don't work you know same
I don't ever want to see a Chinese
person making hummus see
I hope Chinese people look at how much
the same way I look at [__]
disgusting from the Pampas eaters
weakening our nation let this [__]
madness
[__] come out come in and take over
and shoot us this shitty game boyse
every time you eat hummus
you've given a dollar towards terrorism
only this [__] I mean what that [__] my
[__] killed me
I stopped shopping at my super mark I'm
back with the Mexicans Mexicans don't
eat hummus bank [__] god only a few I
got a Mexican supermarket so I want to
hear the [__] animal scream in the
back it's tremendous when we could sit
like this on a Saturday afternoon and
chitchat about nothing
listen to music drink a little water ten
years ago I'm missing a bond what're you
gonna do now select your mate google
chase APB [__] it we'll get another bump
that one breaks a little other one too
that's how we roll but that's it that's
it and that's that we've been here with
you for 20 minutes we smoke we check
there's gotta be up there [__] the
sun's on out cuz there's a fire now
Florido know you wake up to spoil his
ashes on your car the cigarettes throw
like your window half of these white
people were man you know cuz they're
[__] weak
another clear up those lungs from time
to time this is all [__] reliable I
got the lungs of a [__] mule you
understand and that's it and that's that
we're gonna sit back listen the rock
lobster go home
but prospective families but we just
want to touch basically and let you know
[__] it all sincerity we love you have a
great day
that's right love you have a great day
wash your [__]
nobody wants people of the stinky around
them and that's it get out of the
[__] phone life is going on
[__] then you wonder why you're
getting shot in the gay bar look around
you [__] look around you see these
hummus dicks you down by one one and
that's it
I love your [__] stay black have
a great day
UFC tonight